hey 42 here I have a question for you
when was the last time you watch the
news and didn't see bad news when did
you last read a headline that read sorry
folks no news today because all is fine
and dandy in the world apart from that
one day on 18th of April 1940 when there
was no news so they simply played piano
music for 15 minutes instead of the
usual news bulletin yes that actually
happened it's easy to believe that we're
all doomed with the Gaza Strip Isis
Ebola countless civil wars school
shootings killer cops and a handful of
highly questionable world leaders it
seems that every year the world is
falling deeper and deeper into a pit of
hatred deceits murder war terrorism and
despair one could easily believe that
the world is more dangerous now than it
has ever be and only getting more so but
what's the truth are things getting
better or worse
what does the outlook look like for the
future of mankind to find out we need to
do one very important thing completely
ignore every news source in the world
you see there is an intrinsic problem
with news they only reports the bad news
and the worst news is the higher the
building get receives front-page
headlines are reserved for only the most
miserable events often Falls around the
world each day whether it be TV news
tabloids or even social media news
outlets need to attract large numbers of
viewers or they will inevitably fail so
naturally the most compelling stories
are chosen to make headlines well it
makes sense doesn't it by its very
definition news would not be news if it
was not something out of the ordinary
although it's nice to hear reporting
that millions of cars of are safely at
their destinations this week is not news
what reporting the fatal collisions it
and because news only reports the bad
event it gives the majority of people
the impression that these awful events
are far more likely to occur than they
actually do
headlines would have us believe that
terrorists are waiting for us hunting
their next attack around every corner at
every airport or transportation system a
data scientist recently calculated the
odds of a person dying in a terrorist
attack he concluded that your chances
are one in 25 million let me put that
into perspective your chances of dying
in the bathtub is one in six hundred and
eighty thousand so you're 36 times more
likely to die in the tub than at the
hands of a terrorist
also you're 2.5 times more likely to
become a president and two times more
likely to become an astronaut than to
die in a terrorist attack of course this
is no solace for the unfortunate victims
of sorts of attacks but it does go to
demonstrate how news headlines can
artificially inflate our worries and
negative expectations of the world what
the reality it's really rather different
what if despite everything you've heard
and everything you've read I told you
that the world is more peaceful right
now than ever before
many experts including German economist
max Rosa have said that we are currently
living in the most peaceful period of
our species existence Matt Rosa of
Oxford University runs the website our
world in data and this astonishing chart
shows two global deaths in conflicts per
100,000 people
every year since 1400 the past 15 years
have seen a rapid and substantial drop
in conflict deaths worldwide but that's
just in war what about our streets
what about fetched murder and rape well
this graph shows a homicide rate per
100,000
in various European regions between the
year 1300 and today that's quite a
decline but that does go all the way
back to the Middle Ages when your best
friend would bash your head in for a leg
of lamb how about over the past couple
of decades well this graph shows the
rate of robberies homicides and vehicle
thefts across the g7 countries between
1995 and 2010 all three crimes have
reduced significantly but hold on
what about terrorism surely that's
becoming more prevalent each year not a
month goes by when we don't hear about
an awful attack somewhere around the
world yes it's true that jihadist
terrorism has increased over the past
two decades but overall if we take every
event of terrorism from the past 50
years the frequency of attacks has got
significantly especially over the past
decade according to our world in data in
2006 there were 6600 hundred 60 counts
of terrorism worldwide by 2009 that had
dropped to just 560 and the number of
deaths from terrorism has dropped also
[Music]
when we take all these factors and put
them together it creates an interesting
picture as to what is happening with
world peace and that's exactly what the
Institute for economics and peace has
done every year the sydney-based
research firm analyzes thousands of
unique bits of data from every country
and produces a Peace Corps under ranking
for every country on earth calls the
Global Peace Index in their latest 2017
index the five most peaceful countries
on earth are Iceland New Zealand
Portugal Austria and Denmark and the
least peaceful are Syria Afghanistan
Iraq South Sudan and
Yemen what if you look at the change in
each country's Peace Index over the past
10 years something strange has happened
which explains why overall the world is
becoming less violent whilst the
newspapers are doing the opposite and
only filling up with more violence the
peace gap is widening the authors of the
Global Peace Index have stated that over
the past 10 years 81 countries that were
already peaceful have only become more
peaceful yet 79 countries that were
already unpeaceful have become even less
peaceful each year according to the
Global Peace Index Europe is the most
peaceful region in the world and every
year since the index began European
countries have only got more and more
peaceful each year except for France
which has seen a slight drop in rankings
due to the recent terrorist attacks in
the country however the publishers of
the study has said that today most
European countries are now more peaceful
than they have ever been in recorded
history
conversely the world's least peaceful
regions the Middle East and North Africa
have only got less peaceful each and
every year and are now less peaceful
than ever
but as always there is one developed
country that has bucked the trend of
increased peace among its peers not only
how the United States of America dropped
its ranking every year but its peace
index has also fallen faster than any
other major developed country in 2015
the US was ranked 94 out of 163
countries in 2016 it was ranked 103 and
this year it's elegant to 114 of the 163
countries a rapid drop which the
researchers attribute in part to
increased political instability and
divide in recent years
what's at your end of the spectrum how
did Iceland get to be number one on the
list
not only that Iceland has always been
number one for as long as the Global
Peace Index has existed Iceland has been
ranked the most peaceful country on
earth
and the reason behind it is fascinating
Iceland isn't the world's birth
beautiful place because of the country's
remoteness and it's beautiful scenery
although it certainly does help Iceland
is so peaceful because it has to be
Iceland is one of the harshest
environments on the planet and for
hundreds of years the natives have had
to take unusual steps to survive the
bitterly cold unforgiving Tundra if they
spent all their time fighting one
another they would have perished to the
elements so instead they had to work
together to survive mother nature itself
throughout the ages it has been
perfectly acceptable and quite common in
Icelandic culture to enter somebody
else's house even if you have never met
them before and even if they're not home
and make yourself a cup of tea in their
kitchen to warm yourself up that's a
level of trust and community that would
be completely unfathomable for citizens
of most of the countries but it was born
out of necessity for living in such a
cold inhospitable country and although
the terrain is inhospitable the people
are certainly not and their respect and
Trust of one another is what makes
Iceland the most peaceful country in
world the average homicides per year in
the US is 15,000
the average homicides per year in
Iceland is one just one and that truly
is something to be very proud of thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please click here to support me on
patreon which helps the channel and you
can get some cool rewards like early
access to all my videos click here to
watch another video and if you haven't
already don't forget to subscribe